é bom quando eu recebi o convite eu
fiquei tipo chocado que eu vou falar né
eu fiquei chocado principalmente por
três questões
primeiro porque drag queen evento a
gente não vê nem muito difícil
segundo porque eu não sou uma drag queen
que segue aquela estética que
normalmente está na mídia pra gente
e terceiro porque o andré que em falando
sobre como acredita fazer a diferença
como eu percebo essa diferença e eu
falei que eu vou falar e não saber essa
resposta tão claramente eu comecei a
pensar sobre a minha vida e eu fui
percebendo que durante a minha vida até
que hoje alguns eventos e repetiram com
muita freqüência e hoje eu vou trazer
este evento para vocês porque eu
acredito que eles me fizeram quem sou e
me trouxeram aqui pra gente começar eu
vou lá no início quando era muito
pequeno porque se tinha algo que marcava
victor hugo era curiosidade daqueles
meninos que fala assim mãe porque isso
está sentado aí porque não está sentada
lá eu era isso só que dez vezes mais
eu lembro uma vez acho que a primeira
vez que eu fui na praia e aí eu vi que
ele marilyn daquela sonda tudo e eu ver
esse antes de entrar na água mãe que
desliga a onda porque necessitava aquilo
tudo acontecendo tinha alguém que
acreditava que estava fazendo isso mas
não tinha mãe sem falar que é mentira
que ninguém olha a minha curiosidade
também a lei porque ela me trazia
algumas coisas não tão legais
ela vai fazer e eu quebrar todos os
brinquedos eu ganhava
eu não contentava em ver um carrinho lá
andando e eu vi aquilo gente isso é
muito óbvio esse carro andando mas que
está por trás desse carrinho e aí eu ia
lá abrir quebrava de alguma forma porque
eu queria ver como eram os fios como era
o motor que estava acontecendo pra fazer
o carro andar junto com essa questão da
curiosidade se teve uma outra coisa que
marca a minha infância é que eu tinha
interesses um pouco diferente da maioria
eu normalmente gostava de brincar com a
minha prima fazendo comidinha enquanto o
pessoal estava jogando bola
eu gostava de andar com um quadro negro
embaixo do braço para todos os meus
colegas porque eu queria ensinar alguma
coisa e aí você vê essa diferença muito
evidente eu paguei um preço né
meus colegas vão interpretar aquilo bem
e começar a falar assim a vitória o jec
aí olha libertada na luz para todos no
leque ele é gay e aí durante muitos anos
e se repetir repetir repetir um e eu
passei a acreditar que era verdade eu
sou tão diferente quando eu chego as
pessoas falam que eu sou gay eu devo
seguir aí não tem outra explicação
e aí eu pensei comigo gente toda vez que
chega um lugar alguém me olha diferente
alguém pensa que eu sou gay
na minha cabeça eu não quero você essa
vergonha pra minha mãe porque isso é uma
coisa muito ruim então não vou deixar
minha mãe sofrer né
e aí eu achei uma saída eu comecei a
jogar e eu ficava no computador 15 e 16
horas jogando e jogando jogando achando
aquilo tudo incrível e no que eu jogava
eu comecei a ter um problema porque eu
não via personagens que parecem comigo
ou eram muito masculinas portão não era
isso era muito femininos muito frágil e
eu também né isso e aí eu falei gente
alguém está ganhando dinheiro aqui
provavelmente alguém está sendo pago
para fazer isso isso alguém está sendo
paga alguém sabe fazer isso eu também
possa aprender a fazer isso e aí eu fui
comecei a pesquisar comecei a pesquisar
comecei a fazer meus primeiros jogos e
mudando algumas coisas criando novos
personagens e mostrando para os meus
amigos na internet e todo mundo achava
muito legal
nunca vi esse personagem é que diferente
enfim acharam muito legal e aí eu virei
pra mim não é falecida mãe
vou formar agora eu vou começar a
estudar jogos digitais porque descobri
que tem aqui em bh e eu vou fazer porque
está todo mundo falando que gosta do que
eu faço
e aí eu fui e entra na graduação sempre
com aaa a competição na minha cabeça que
eu era muito
diferente de todo mundo e na graduação
como a gente está falando de jogo
ninguém estava preocupado se eu era
muito diferente não só quero jogo né ai
que acontece a gente começou a entender
a teoria dos jogos e aí lá na segunda o
terceiro período uma professora me vejo
assim
o trabalho final de vocês vai fazer um
jogo com uma criança com síndrome de
down ótimo né
são maus e jogo foi uma criança sem
transtornos em síndrome alguma onde quem
virá pra uma que têm algum transtorno
alguma síndrome e aí eu queria resolver
isso que ele resolvesse da fia e eu fui
em várias áreas do conhecimento atrás de
informação vai permitir que estes jogos
são francisco logia foi na pedagogia e
eu fui percebendo que o mais
interessante do que criar o jogo em si
era o caminho que eu fazia eu me sentir
muito realizado quando eu ia lá achava
uma peça pegava essa peça trazer pra cá
e isso me fazia me senti muito bem e aí
que eu resolvi fazer mãe aqui não tá
dando é muito focado em programação mas
eu achei uma universidade do sul do país
que lá tem essa área e eu vou pra lá
minha mãe né tipos e 2 elas sozinho vou
o porquê primeiro eu queria resolver
essa questão os jogos que eu amava mas
tinha outro motivo
mãe tem 210 revelação tinha outro motivo
que era porque eu precisava saber quem
era victor hugo victor hugo era
diferente não era de falar a vida toda
então tinha que saber isso e eu fui para
o sul e descobriu que mudou minha vida
eu descobri que era gay
e aí quando eu era gay gente nunca
tiveram ainda só numa balada gay porque
vocês vão ver a música divertida só
coisa legal todo mundo te olhando e aí
você vai é perceber que você se sente
reconhecido que as pessoas se olham e
você existe no mundo e quando a gente
existe no mundo é uma coisa se inscreva
situação como eu estava lá fazendo jogos
estudando e tudo eu comecei a questionar
os meus
amigos será que nós gays não estamos nos
jogos você se bem nos jogos e aí eles
também tinham diferentes opiniões e tudo
e eu falei é preciso saber mais
precisamente sobre isso e que eu fiz
comecei a pesquisar fazendo pesquisa com
todo mundo e essas pesquisas embora aqui
não tem um trago nenhuma invalidação
nada de interessante no insight muito
útil
vocês vão ver que daqui a pouco ela vai
mudar minha vida formei no sul
a vida me trouxe para bh e aí eu entrei
numa confecção de roupa
até então eu não gostava de moda não
encontrava imerso concentrei na
confecção de roupas e eu tinha que saber
que eu estava fazendo e eu comecei a
fazer fui me interessando e nessa
confecção começou tem um incômodo muito
grande pra mim na hora do almoço ficava
todo mundo parado no celular eo gente
tanto de conhecimento aqui ninguém está
trocando nada aqui coisa precisa de
alguma coisa e aí eu virei e falei gente
eu sei informática básica e vocês sabem
costura eu quero costurar vocês querem
aprender informática vão trocar ea gente
começou a trocar foi costurando eu fui
aprendendo a mostrar se interessando por
aquilo e com um ano mais ou menos de
serviço
eu fiquei focado sufocado por que eu
trabalhava na parte administrativa na
parte administrativa não sentia num
círculo preso eu não podia fazer muita
coisa não podia muito além e à costura
me permitia ir pra onde eu quisesse mas
muito além desse círculo e eu falei não
dá mais não não consigo trabalhar assim
e eu sair vou focado já em voltar para a
área de jogos
quando eu voltei para a área dos jogos
eu fui atrás de uma equipe tudo e nesse
meio do caminho
eu conheço um programa meus amigos
apresentar um programa sobre os
participantes que criam diferentes
personagens fazem roupas fazem coisas
muito diferentes uns falam assim a sua
tara isso é um exercício de criatividade
pra você não faz enfim vai lá e faz a
gente tá mesmo tem que entender isso e
eu comecei a acompanhar comecei a
pesquisar em tudo e eu vi que era muito
leve
e eu virei e falei eu quero ter essa
experiência mesmo que seja um personagem
que dure alguns minutos algumas horas eu
quero ter essa experiência
e aí surge a vitória invicta que é um
personagem uma performance artística que
a base dela é não ter um rosto ela é a
diferença a minha diferença
materializada a cada dia uma coisa só há
quase uma semana de um jeito é de um
jeito ea forma do mal é de outro jeito e
isso pessoalmente nos satisfaz muito
porque eu participei de todo o processo
e se isso me satisfaz pessoalmente e os
jogos
eu gosto de jogos ele também nos
satisfazem porque eu não posso unir
essas duas coisas e aí eu falei lembra
aquelas pesquisas lá atrás
elas apareciam com muita repetição que
as pessoas queriam jogos que eram muito
diferentes que traziam personagens muito
diferentes e se eu tinha tomado um
personagem mil que era muito diferente
as pessoas queriam personagens
diferentes porque não juntar essas duas
coisas eu jantei essas duas coisas e aí
eu já tinha uma equipe é formada eu
falei gente vamos ter jogos é que é uma
drag queen e eu decidi eu falei não vai
ter mais vitórias em três jogos na
vitória que jogos porque representa uma
parte do que essas pessoas têm interesse
e é uma satisfação minha pessoal ea
gente desenvolver o nosso primeiro
projeto e vieram algumas coisas que a
gente não esperava
a gente começou tanto feedback ieso mais
feedback os mais variados possíveis
uns muito positivos uns muito negativos
só que as pessoas estão falando da gente
e antes de eu me senti muito mal com que
estava vendo muito feliz
eu era muito curioso e eu quis ver um
pouco estava à frente disso eu pensei
assim porque está acontecendo será que
não tem nenhum 11 justificativa pra
estas feedback está mesmo sendo dada a
mim ea minha ficha caiu
a fala de gente nós estamos no mundo que
está todo mundo brigando por atenção eu
estou trazendo a minha diferença e eu
tendo a atenção das pessoas
se o tênis
as pessoas eu tenho a oportunidade de
mostrar que a minha diferença é muito
legal a diferença delas também pode ser
muito legal não é diferente e é isso que
faz um mundo ser divertidos e diferentes
a partir desse momento então eu virei e
falei olha agora eu só vou trazer jogos
focados na diferença porque é uma
oportunidade que eu tenho que eu vejo de
mudar o mundo porque as precisas as
pessoas precisam entender que a
diferença que é o que deixa o mundo mais
interessante é nessa jornada a gente
entrar num finalizar aqui eu percebi
diversas coisas eu aprendi no final dos
conceitos passei por diversas áreas mas
aprendi principalmente o vitor não se
resume a victor
o victor não se resume à vitória o
victor se resume a uma infinidade de
possibilidades e é isso que faz o vitor
criar jogos são diferentes porque ele
tem a liberdade de quem ele quiser
ainda mais dentro no jogo mas se eu
pudesse responder àquela pergunta que
abre essa conversa hoje o porquê de eu
estar aqui em cima desse palco
eu diria que o motivo que me trouxe aqui
foi porque eu tinha convicção desde o
início de que fazer a diferença não é só
ter dinheiro reconhecimento poder é só
deixar de lado que você é se colocar no
lugar do outro e ver o mundo com novos
olhos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]